we're back i'm sitting here with serena
williams
i really want to play you in tennis the
problem is we don't have enough room in
here to play uh
an actual tennis match so we were
wondering if you would play me
in the nintendo wii tennis game are you
up for it
let's go follow me right over here this
is right here we're gonna set this up
of course i uh i like to be dressed for
your kids oh cool
[Applause]
you're intimidating me then why are you
laughing so hard all right i haven't
really done this before someone's going
to get us started here because i don't
know what i'm doing does anybody know
what we're doing here
here's aaron blair going to show me what
i'm doing huh
nice job huh nice
oh okay who's serving here uh you're
serving i'm serving
all right check it out cause here comes
the master
huh
oh okay oh
but see my form here let's see my form
oh okay here we go all right
here we go
i don't even know what happened there
what happened there okay i have no idea
what happened
oh what happened there i'm wearing my
outfit from
australia you've been partying too hard
okay here i come again
that was a great shot oh that was uh you
got lucky there because here i
come again
[Music]
i think you just killed some people
oh look at that nice oh all right here
we go
and
[Music]
backhand oh out oh
the hell was that
[Music]
[Applause]
that was the end you're yelling at
nintendo wii all right let's play this
anymore
all right here we go here's game point
here we go yeah
ah
all right thank you very much that was
fun that's my dream come true take a
break serena williams everybody
you